I’ve never owned a precon.
Wizards of the Coast has been releasing preconstructed
commander decks every year since I started
playing in 2011, and with increasing frequency,
and I’ve just kept on ignoring them.
The reason for this is simple enough—I didn’t
start playing commander until 2014, at which
point I felt like a skilled enough player
to build my own mono black removal pile to
piss off my friends.
However, as I’ve continued to make videos
and exist more in the MTG-space, it’s become
increasingly clear to me that precons play
a major role in the way people learn and conceptualize
the EDH format, so I figure I should take
a moment to engage with the world of precons.
I polled my patrons, and they thought I should
take a look at the Blame Game precon, so I’m
going to do just that—I’m going to breakdown
what I think the deck is trying to do, how
well it’s accomplishing that plan, and some
potential improvement routes for making it
function better.
Let’s first break down what the commander
is offering.
Nelly’s first ability contains the “suspect”
component, which offers immediate evasion
by disabling a blocker, as well as the goad
component, which offers a way to keep threats
away from our life total as long as Nelly
keeps attacking, and guarantees that our opponents
will be attacking each other.
The second ability is a source of draw that
can offer up to three cards per turn cycle,
while also feeding opponents that resource
as a reward for hitting each other, whether
due to being compelled or otherwise.
This is a pretty fun package—the first ability
will scale to great effect over time, and
the second ability offers some fun politics
gameplay and discourages our opponents from
removing Nelly for fear of losing out on those
sweet, sweet cards.
Less to the point of this video, the flavor
here is great—a commander that is constantly
accusing people of murder, which is causing
the accused to lash out in order to curry
favor as long as Nelly is around, good stuff.
To go along with the commander, the deck is
running lots of cards with the intent of getting
our opponents to attack each other rather
than attacking us.
There are a bunch of other goad cards, there
are cards that give people advantages for
attacking our opponents, there are cards that
punish people for attacking us, and so on.
Basically, this deck is trying to control
the midgame by getting our opponents to fight
amongst themselves, and Nelly draws us additional
cards when they do this.
This card draw should hopefully fuel a powerful
late game, where a suite of bigger creatures
means that once our opponents are dropping
in life total and dwindling in number, we
can take control of the game with our boardstate.
So that’s the gameplan, but how effectively
can the deck accomplish it?
Well, there are a handful of things that the
deck is doing decently well when it comes
to fundamentals.
It has eight cards that I can broadly label
as “draw”, which isn’t a bad number
when paired with a commander that will likely
be drawing 1-2 cards per turn cycle.
There are also eleven cards that one could
label as ramp, which is also a solid number,
and this number also works well with a creature
base that includes a number of higher-costed
beaters.
Finishing off the final opponent is something
I’d naturally worry about for a goad deck,
but I think the creature base is just beefy
enough that the deck should be able to finish
off a game a lot of the time, as long as the
commander has been getting in the desired
number of draw triggers.
The deck contains nine cards that I’d call
removal, and although I’m a little concerned
at how high-cost most of it is, I’m mostly
willing to overlook that due to how many other
options the deck has for interacting with
opposing creatures.
The deck includes ten extra goad cards, which
bolster the commander’s card draw and will
also help keep the heat off us even if our
commander-based goad engine goes offline.
What I don’t like is the amount of other
player-protective cards in this deck.
I tallied up all the cards that discourage
or disallow attacking us in some way, and
the total for these was 33 cards.
One third of the deck is trying to get our
opponents to attack each other instead of
us.
And I get that that’s a big thing the deck
is trying to do, but 33 deck slots is way
too many for a task that won’t win or prevent
our opponents from winning on its own.
Like okay, the ideal scenario is that you’ll
have key opposing creatures being tossed around
wildly with opposing gameplans and life totals
crumbling before our very eyes, but how often
will this actually happen?
There will be games where our opponents are
developing horrifying wincons that don’t
use combat, and we just sit there twiddling
our thumbs as we goad their utility 2/3s into
Johnny-no-board over there and draw them into
the gas they need to murder us.
My guess is that different defensive cards
are meant to serve somewhat different purposes
throughout the game, but this is quite inefficient
slots-wise.
Additionally, and this is kind of a precon
classic, but the manabase is bad.
37 lands might be an okay count in the abstract,
but it includes 11 solely-colorless-producing
utility lands.
This results in the deck having 20 white sources
and 17 red sources between its artifacts and
lands.
That’s right, this 37 land and 6 rock two
color mana base has symbol numbers that are
similar to those of the budget 30 land, four
color mana base from my lands video.
And this deck has like 10 double red cards
in it—you need 26 red sources to consistently
cast a Vengeful Ancestor on curve, and here
we are with 17.
Wizards please.
Just put things that tap for colored mana
in your precons.
Just do it, I know you can.
Thank you.
I ran 15 playtests with the deck, and my previous
hunches were pretty well backed up.
The deck can have a decent mid game curve-out
with solid ramping and drawing capabilities,
but it frequently has mana issues and also
frequently gets stuck with a hand full of
nothing but niche defensive cards.
Another issue that was on my radar but which
became much more clear in playtesting was
that the deck has only a handful of good three
drops, and basically no two drops other than
mana rocks.
When I playtested it I was aggressively mulliganing
for early plays, which led to the deck having
what I’d consider to be a decent curve out
8 of the 15 playtests, but I imagine a new
player piloting the deck would probably happily
keep a more average hand for the deck, one
that plays nothing on turn 1 and 2, a weird
enchantment on turn 3, and commander turn
4.
Which, I guess might work out in a game with
other precons, but leaving your two drop slot
on the table in a two color deck is not good
and will hurt your chances of winning.
So yeah, there are definitely issues here,
but overall, this deck has a very fun, useful
commander and a pretty solid midgame plan
of influencing the attacks of the game and
leveraging politics to its favor.
It’s pretty well-rounded in most areas,
with the three standout issues being manabase,
mana curve, and an excess of player-protective
cards.
So how do we go about tuning it up?
For improving this deck, I want to maintain
the affordability and spirit of the deck,
but smooth out some of the rough edges.
First of all, I would cut a bunch of defensive
cards, because they are taking up too much
goddamn space in this deck.
Specifically, I dislike the ones whose use
cases are too narrow, whose effect is too
limited, or which cost too much mana, and
there are about a quarter of these that I’d
cut right off the bat.
From there I think it’s up to the player
to some extent—I opted to cut an additional
six for my final decklist.
In their place there are a number of things
that could be added, and I think a good option
to somewhat fill the same role is cards that
grant haste.
If Nelly dies on declare combat step, well
that sucks for us, but if she dies any other
time we want to be able to play her again
and keep her wall of goad up.
I’d also add a bit of board protection in—if
Nelly gets destroyed we’re vulnerable to
attacks, and if the board gets wiped we lose
basically all momentum.
Next up, let’s talk manabase.
The goal here is simple—we want several
more symbols of each color, and to get there
we cut colorless lands and rocks for ones
that produce colored mana.
I like a lot of the utility lands in principle—evasion
is good, graveyard hate is good, draw is good—so
I’m going to start with the ones I see as
adding basically nothing to the deck.
Temple of the False God is weird and very
bad if you’re running less than, like, 43
other lands.
Reliquary Tower and Thought Vessel are next
up on my shit list—this deck doesn’t draw
insane numbers of cards, and it also isn’t
doesn’t need to hold up a bunch of interaction
and niche tech pieces.
I’d also cut Kher Keep, and I’d consider
cutting some number of Scavenger Grounds,
Throne of the High City, and Sunhome if the
deck was going to stay at the same land count,
though these cards at least have some identifiable
purpose here.
Speaking of land count, I think there are
two options for this deck with regard to mana
curve.
Option A would be to keep the higher curve,
add a couple lands, and add 4-5 two cost mana
rocks to make sure we’re able to swing with
the commander on turn 4 as often as possible.
I’d also fill out the deck with a few more
beaters in order to better guarantee that
we’ll have the raw power to finish off the
final player.
Option B would be to drop the curve, and add
a bunch of 2 and 3 drop creatures that could
lead us to having a more aggressive gameplan.
I think either of these two gameplans would
be valid, but in my list I went for option
A, as it seemed more in-line with the original
plan of the deck.
Though you could certainly make a much better
deck with this commander, my goal here was
to only swap out 20 cards, to scrape out a
bit of the precon jank factor and make the
deck play more smoothly.
I posted both the original deck as well as
the improved version I made in the description,
so you can check out the changes I made and
let me know in the comments if you think I
utterly bastardized the entire point of the
deck.
This is also a bit different than most of
my other videos, so you can also let me know
if this sort of content is something you want
to see more of in the future.
Alright, bye now.